darf ich sagen wollte ich kenne doch du
kannst besser machen hallo ich bin's
hast du mich erkannt herr jung wie wäre
es mit uns beiden
doch hier mit conti manager muss und
dann krieg ich kein zurück ich habe
keinen bock mehr auf den ganzen scheiß
hey baby ich liebe dich so dass uns die
flitterwochen genießen das ist mein turn
hier okay
das war das abgesprochen wie gemein sagt
gegeben
hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es wieder
eine neue folge kicking
mit minute jubeln
also heute gibt es eine folge kiez mit
der wunderbaren es war du trägst du
mehrere persönlichkeiten in den job los
ganz so sagen du bist der
synchronsprecherin und wir haben es uns
gelungen seitlich im monat versuchen wir
rasten jaja kommt hin jetzt kann es
endlich geschafft ist extra nach berlin
angereist und ich glaube das wird eine
richtig spannende folge geräumig stellt
doch mal so in zwei sätzen vor um sich
alter sagen musst du dich da steckt doch
meinen namen drin es um 83 also schnell
mit 38 ich kann weder waffen noch kochen
das ist längst noch interessanter ich
spreche synchron und zwar jetzt seit 28
jahren genau was angefangen mails sehen
zehn heftig so auch keine ausbildung du
bist doch richtig reingerutscht bin da
reingewachsen okay kann man das
interesse hat das ist einfach von anfang
an oder nein es war tatsächlich zufall
eine klassenkameradin julia kaufmann ok
auch bekannt deswegen nenne ich den
namen gerade die hat das als kind schon
immer gemacht und die ganze zeit
unterwegs und mussten immer zu zweit
synchronisieren und einmal ist das eine
kind ausgefallen ihre partnerinnen und
sie hat ihm spontan vater ist halt zu
bist du auch mit commons und mit mir
sind grund mich das tor das ist
gefordert nein sagte ich habe mir gar
nichts darunter vorstellen können ich
dachte so ok habe ich versuchen aber ich
wusste nicht was sie damit meint
das wird verlost sich um so weiter und
so fort dachte ich okay ich probier's
mal aus weil ich gerne mit der zeit
verbracht habe jan an standen die
plötzlich im atelier und bei uns einfach
ein bildschirm und in dem nebenraum die
regie mit dem tonmeister der tonmeister
lang richtig programmiert total und ich
dachte sogar das ist mir ruhig sein wenn
rot war weil das ausnahme ich konnte
damit nicht umgehen also ich muss
erstmal da sozusagen gekommen über das
zehn mal so verstand aber ich habe mich
an die erste szene erinnern das waren
zwei kinder die auf dem spielplatz waren
geschaukelt haben wir mussten nur lachen
auch gelang habe ich erst verstanden was
dahintersteckt sozusagen also das wird
für mich war alles was ich gesehen habe
schon fertig deutsch kraft und da habe
ich verstanden was da im prozess hinter
ist dass die leute aufnehmen sozusagen
das vom englischen sozusagen oder aus
anderen sprach ganze mal dieses
kindersachen jetzt mal so ganz spontan
machen immer lachen ja oh gott ich weiß
nicht ob ich das noch herstellen kann
ich könnte zum beispiel gretchen machen
kannst du taktieren hier hast du 1000er
wege wochen am anfang sieht es ganz
einfach eine simple quadratische
gleichungen aber dann stößt man auf
dieses problem
peking dazu was sag immer einen satz ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich den von gretchen
habe aber der wird sich mega intelligent
eingestuft okay in meiner absicht
soziologischen konstellation
manifestiert sich die absolute dominanz
positiver im konzern des individuums
gretchen business große pause habe ich
geliebt so danne okay ich direktbank
tokio haus des geldes daher riechst du
auf
die kette zwischen leben und tod und
deine beste freundin verloren hast dann
kommt ihr diese 100 stunden die hundert
jahre vor ansonsten hast du mal pretty
little liars area
ich will das alles nicht höre ich meine
zeit so sagt würde irgendwas ändern
highschool musical japan die habe ich
auch sehr gerne rudi gesprochen
[Musik]
dann ist das
ansonsten immer mal hier und dort einige
räume abgeben ist aber sehr bescheiden
weil es unwahrscheinlich die liste ist
so lange und das ist schon echt
beeindruckend und vielleicht kann es ja
wird im laufe des videos mal die eine
oder andere rolle jahr aufstocken müssen
die kommt erscheint oder automaten okay
also was machen wir heute ja da mir
gedacht weil du weder bugs noch kochs
machen richtig einfachen no way kuchen
ok auf basis von löffelbiskuits da
kannst du direkt mal loslegen also heute
machst du das alles okay das ist okay
das werde ich ab jetzt immer immer
machen soll wenn jemand zu besuch kommt
noch dass gegen mit dem natel bist genau
das so dein goto rezept also immer sind
immer eine ein löffel bis 25
die form legen okay und ich darf dich
heute mit fragen durchlöcherte ok
perfekte freilich haben direkt mal eine
frage zu der entstehungsgeschichte
seiner karriere woher dann kann das
traditionelle ausbildung nein aber du
musst ja auch emotionen wut trauer
freude muss das irgendwie lärm na ja
hast du hast du das setzt also man wie
gesagt so man wächst ja tatsächlich rein
was wahrscheinlich genauso wie wenn du
hier wachs und kochs dann wirst du auch
mit jedem mal einfach besser und
verfeinert alles vor allem in serien
wenn du in eine rolle ständig steckst
dann kommst du wächst du mit ihr in die
rolle reihen wächst mit ihren die
emotionen rein und lernst irgendwann
automatisch du siehst die räume von dir
bewusst zu dieser rolle was so schlecht
kann ich hatte das erste mal hatte ich
das gefühl tatsächlich als sich bereich
selbst pubertieren nun habe ich weiß ich
hab mir das kenn ich glaube ihr seid die
jugend noch
ungemein das nicht gerade ein kompliment
und mir gegeben es ist
genauso ein
doch hier nicht kommentarlos und dann
krieg ich keins zurück
entschuldige
noch mal mit
zum renn
ja okay du bist also voll in der rolle
drin auch wenn ich schon ein paar jahre
her
weil ich bin ein auf hilfe die hatte so
pubertäts phasen auf jeden fall ich
gemerkt ich komme so abgefuckt nach
hause dabei hätte ich keine probleme
aber meine rolle hatte ständig
irgendwelche probleme habe und dann habe
ich das tatsächlich mitgenommen und da
habe ich zum ersten mal kitschig zu
verinnerlichen scheinbar deine rollen so
habe ich das mal beobachtet das
tatsächlich so geblieben ok und wo du
jetzt tokio gesprochen hast wolltest du
eine bank ausrauben oder kriegen es eine
sehr logische konsequenz daraus gezogen
hat muss ich vorsichtig sein nein
tatsächlich nicht also ich hab die
distanz zu den rollen aber in dem moment
bin ich sie was ich nur habe dass ich zu
der einen oder anderen rolle eine
emotion auf bauer also tokio hat für
mich tatsächlich eine sehr große
bedeutung mittlerweile und gerade jetzt
so ballhaus des geldes wenn sie jetzt da
auch so sehnen wie zum beispiel
erotische sehen oder so sind die solche
sachen noch mal unangenehm gar nicht ich
gar nicht ja doch tatsächlich schon also
ich versuche das so professionell wie
möglich
ich hoffe nur dass meine eltern nicht zu
weil es so sagt das so professionell wie
möglich zu machen aber gehört schon zu
den unangenehmeren jobs also ist ja
nicht so dass ich einen kompletten für
aber es sind sie hat schon erotik szenen
sie ist erotisch sein ist mal was
anderes als eine bettszene zum beispiel
die es erst noch für den moment habe ich
dann nicht cool aber ich kriege es dann
doch in mario kart und dann wird sie
professionell und dann wie viele leute
hören die dann zu wehren ohne fehler
also du hast katar cutterin im atelier
atelier sohn enzo oder studio in dem du
auf nämlich sozusagen die sitzt mit dir
drin 11 die synchronität sozusagen
zuständig dann hast du in der regie die
regie doch irgendeine art und weise sich
entweder vor die hier neben oder hinter
gitter über eine scheibe und dann
kommuniziert ihr miteinander regisseur
regisseurinnen tonmeister ton meisterin
das heißt minimum drei leute gucken okay
das ist jetzt nicht gedacht sagt ok
einer ist da um cholera ist ob er
tatsächlich und was war so die
unangenehmste rolle im allgemeinen spiel
und deutlich sprechen musste ist
unangenehm im sinne von das hat mir
keinen spaß gemacht das kommt hin und
wieder vor aber weil ich einfach mit der
materie mich nicht identifizieren kann
also ich sehe mich in der rolle nicht
ich sehe mich in dem ganzen film
irgendwie dem ganzen projekt nicht das
wird ein bisschen schwierig das gute ist
das ja das team wertete das sozusagen
auf wenn du mit dem team um gut klar
kommt dann ist im prinzip letztendlich
egal was du sprichst und meine nächste
frage ist passt jetzt gerade sagst du
auch alle rollen zu oder bist du so weit
und daher also ich glaub mal entweder
weil es zu viel ist gerade oder weil mir
das projekt nicht gefällt oder
tatsächlich wollen wir irgendetwas an
der situation nicht gefällt dann also
wenn es zum beispiel meistens nicht
professionelles ich mir schon wichtig
dass jede position belegt dass also das
getaktet wird dass der tonmeister die
meisterinnen drin ist der regisseur dass
mir wichtig auf qualität
das ist doch super wichtig weil sonst
macht das ganze auch kein leben ok also
im boden hast du schon mal so
brauche er für julia in not aus habe ich
das mal an mir
kleben dafür würde ich nicht bitten dass
du einfach mal seine aufstieg das ist
bestimmt schon tausend mal gemacht also
seien auch das wirklich so
[Gelächter]
ich kann das ist
ja ja ich mache mein
prozession er ja so jetzt aber also ja
so toll ausgeschlagen habe aufgepasst
allerdings mit erstmal fängst du
ja genau so machen jetzt hier mit hier
geht es beantwortest du jetzt ist habe
ich mir vorher gesagt und ich möchte
dich jetzt etwas tut mal wir haben das
mit der sahne gemacht die mal flüssig
und jetzt ist sie so geht es müssen dann
geht das zu zeigen wir eigentlich nicht
okay alles professionell okay so jetzt
musst du sagen weiß was als nächstes
kommen auf die also du hast gerade bei
gebracht ich glaube man muss das
zusammensuchen bist so gut es geht weil
das ist nämlich
weil das weißt du gar nicht
das ist es nämlich philadelphia nämlich
ja stimmt ja ja ja ja
also das hier ist ja maskat ohne kitsch
und
da kommt neben ausgaben von mir
geschlagene sahne das ist nicht von mir
geschlagen dass sie von mir geschlagen
und das ist nämlich backpulver mischen
ja ich habe die frage was ist was ist
denn das jetzt hier das ist dass wir ja
ja das ist die
[Musik]
zahl auf
mandeln und ein bisschen stefan der man
das sehen sie ja da ist sie geworden
das ist die geschlagen hier sehen wir
aber auch komischer weise geschlagen es
ist auch das aufgeschlagene sagen ist
natürlich ist auch geschlagen als
geschlagene sahne alles was weiß ist ist
geschlagene sahne aber ich habe nicht
jede sahne geschlagen hier genau alles
ist irgendwie sagen das ist nämlich
natron ja
[Gelächter]
ein bisschen
stört ja okay
ich bin schon diesmal packen wir uns
nicht sagen hallo ich bin's hast du mich
erkannt was soll ich das mach' mal
stellt die gerade tokio vor okay stell
dir vor wie sie auf rio zugeht und trio
versucht
zurückzugewinnen okay okay und dann
sagst du nein sagen es anders rio
wäre es mit uns beiden
nein ich witzig wie zu machen mario
du hast ja
[Gelächter]
werden
so aber schön dass wir nicht backen wir
so rumalbern ich möchte ja was wäre also
ich vom nato in die zahnpasta
gemischt mit philadelphia genau natron
zahnpasta willi und alles für ein ich
habe euch die ganz genauen mengenangaben
unten in die info box
verbinden alle mit einem übrigens noch
ein synchronsprecher hier sag mal was
hinter der kamera bei hallo hier ist das
bundesamt für süßigkeiten für die
empfehlung
ist keine verfehlung er ist der beste
wir hören jetzt einfach alle zutaten bis
auf eine richtig schön geschlagene sahne
in dieser schüssel zusammen und was mich
interessieren würde ist also ich als
youtube auch nicht jeden tag den
gleichen rhythmus und alltag nur wie ist
das bei dir ja auch mega unterschied
nicht spannend sind am tage wenn ich zum
beispiel morgens eine zeichentrick
prinzessin spreche zum beispiel hey ich
bin eine kleine prinzessin und die welt
sieht so rosarot arzt komme ich aus dem
termin und dann mache ich zum nächsten
termin und das ist dann irgendeine queck
süchtige prostituierte im gefängnis
gelandet das und gesagt ich hab keinen
bock mehr auf den ganzen scheiß
rassist in dreck in der stimmung und
dann kommst du wieder nach hause noch
nicht so halt so eine liebende keine
romantische frau die mit ihrem freund
gerade in den flitterwochen ist und dann
sagt sie hey baby ich liebe dich so
lasst uns die flitterwochen genießen und
das crazy das macht dich übrigens schon
ja glaub ich aber das macht spaß ist es
schön du kannst in unterschiedliche
rollen schlüpfen und versprach nicht
wagen also man kauft ihr das auch sofort
ab er hoffe die alles sofort auf das ist
so kraft kannst du dich selbst noch
hören wenn du dann so guckst du dir das
auch anderen ist das eigentlich eher
selten weil mich das stört weil ich mit
meiner arbeit konzentriert bin weil ich
denke dass jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen
besser machen können
ich krieg nicht so viel von dem mit was
ich gemacht habe ja also eher selten
nahe und ich ja ein bisschen ein problem
damit mir das anzugucken meine stimme
nicht so nein er hast du nicht durch
services wie es ist dann bei dir guckst
du dir deine videos kenne ich mache ja
okay bei mir ist noch zweimal die woche
ein rezept wie du ich lasse schon
manchmal nebenbei laufen ja nochmal so
gegenzug aber also allein schon weil du
weißt du was alles passiert in der serie
oder kukksi dir nur deine abschnitte
nein wo wirklich meine szenen sogar
nicht ein muss auf reisen für beendet
für mich ist das wichtig wenn meine
rolle wenn das für meine rolle
interessant ist dann nur dann auch alles
anderes too much information als spieler
doch mal ein bisschen was passiert denn
bei horses jahren darf ich definitiv
nicht werde ich auch nicht vorhaben und
alles was ich sagen kann es mega
spannend aber es kann auch sein ist es
leute gibt hier noch keine hauses
gesehen haben also müssen die erste
staffel deswegen allgemein ist und ich
sagen ja kräuter sind doch ich finde es
gibt nicht er hatte gerrit als zu
spoilern wenn ich auch unterhauses geld
hast du dir doch bestimmt er angeguckt
oder ihr haus das geld das habe ich mir
so nicht auf einen sozial genau also ich
hab reingeguckt sogar halb wurde nur um
das zu verstehen und dann hat es mich
auch gequetscht ok hat ein bisschen
gedauert aber irgendwann war ich auch
drin okay ja und dann wenn jemand würde
in denen der tod stirbt bekommt weißt du
dass vor lange im voraus
sein job geht nur noch bis donnerstag
und dann bist du tot so nach dem motto
dahin tatsächlich also gerade bei haus
des geldes nicht da hat unsere
regisseurin ina sehr darauf bestanden
dass wir das miterleben sozusagen live
also während wir sprechen und dann hab
ich bei wie das war so ein sch ich habe
einfach komplett gar nicht damit
gerechnet wenn du den charakter sterben
siehst ist es für dich ein schockmoment
also du wirst ja total eingeführt ins
kalte wasser geschmissen sozusagen also
ich hab's und deswegen kannst du die
emotion wahrscheinlich auch viel
authentischer rüberbringen
das ist echt gut das ist klug er war
nicht hier ja ok und was mich
interessieren ach so wirst du mal beton
bisschen ja ja nicht hier von der arbeit
oder das jetzt was welches haben wir
jetzt maßnahme genau das haben was
klappt ohne das hier ist magerquark
dann mache ich noch puderzucker vanille
extrakt und zitrone mit rein das ist ja
heute alles nebensache
mich würde interessieren
gibt es einen charakter den du
gesprochen aus dem volk gerne mal
persönlich treffen würde ist ja ashley
tisdale ok unbedingt die habe ich meiner
meinung nach immer gesprochen bisher so
fest stimme
und ich mag sie irgendwie ich habe bei
ihr das gefühl wenn ich und lucy hale
aber
immer auf die sprünge ist das noch mal
von pretty little liars area okay die
hat auch ganz viele firmen mittlerweile
gemacht und bei den beiden charakteren
also ersteht sl deswegen weil ich sie
sehr sehr humorvoll finde ich mag ihren
humor sehen der kommt meinem sehr nahe
und lucy hale einfach weil ich fühle
weil ich mittlerweile in jedem film auch
wenns neuer film ist und ich meinen
ersten drehtag habe
und wir das erstmal aufnehmen dann mach
ich das gefühl dass ich wenn ich die
sehe direkt weiß was jetzt als nächstes
machen wird also ich verstehe sie direkt
und das macht sie einfach und für mich
auch natürlicher dann rüber zu bringen
gibt es eine solche verträge dass du
jetzt okay schließlich das ist immer
meine richtung das ist also dass ich das
nicht ja so ist es zb hatte ich mal bei
einer schauspielerin tatsächlich noch
mal nachgeforscht und gefragt ob ich ob
das
nicht irgendwie mit mir in verbindung
gebracht werden könnte weil ich sie sehr
gern gesprochen und hat sie zugestimmt
okay wir müssen wir nur noch diese
beiden krebs vereinen am besten also ich
habe jetzt hier den teig aber nicht mehr
den schnäbeln und mit ganzen liebe also
wirklich nur immer so ein bisschen davon
ausmachen mit viel liebe unterrühren und
dann das nächste also für mich daran
gewöhnen dass ich hier wirklich nur
zugucken und nichts machen musst du bist
wunderschön wall street noch richtig
schön komplimente machen du bekommst
liebe von allen das pferd vor
ja ich merke bestimmt richtig lecker
jetzt dadurch euro was soll denn so die
schwerste rolle die duh sprechen muss
dass die schwerste rolle
ok doch die schwerste rolle
und zwar ich muss mal
eine rolle sprechen eigentlich waren
alle skeptisch ob ich die sprech also
nicht weil ich sie sprechen sollte
sondern das schwierige war an dieser
rolle dass es eigentlich erst mal eine
17 jährige war
mit
anfang 50 ok ich glaube ende 20 anfang
30 oder ok und ja und ich sollte eine
17-jährige sprechen was gar kein problem
ist aber das interessante an der ganzen
sache war ich sollte später wird diese
17-jährige rolle eine 40 jährige ich
weiß sicher fühlen das ist ist dass die
seinem film wo die leben tauschen nein
auch kleiner wie also sehr interessant
gemacht sehr schöner film ich komme
jetzt nicht auf den titel aber
tatsächlich ist es so die war sehr
prägnant auch schon am anfang 17 jährige
völlig dieses leichte jugendliche völlig
happy mit den crazy das leben lieben und
später das ist den 40-jährigen
gebrochene frau und ein 40 jähriger
gebrochene frau die durch die straßen
läuft mit ihrem
ungeborenen kind das sie verloren hat
und hat seine tasche und dann läuft sie
herum macht die ganze zeit
selbstgespräche völlig gestört crazy
aber solche rollen liebe ich das war
eine herausforderung die muster zum
einen jung kling dann muss ich sehr alt
kling und vereins zu dieses gebrochene
mitnehmen und kannst du doch das war
jetzt auf die schnelle mal somit einsatz
oder ist das jetzt das ist schwierig ich
müsste die rolle sehen aber ich könnte
es versuchen herzustellen es wäre aber
längst nicht so gut
okay aber vielleicht kann ich ja den den
film in die kommentare schreiben
zu erinnern ja dann könnte man sich ja
auf jeden fall empfehlenswert würde ich
auf jeden fall empfehlen du bist ja
jetzt nimm kronen sprecherin ist das so
dass so ein hang zur schauspielerei hast
oder er gar nicht so muss man haben
meiner meinung nach also wenn mich jetzt
jemand fragen würde was oft passiert
kann ich den kronen sprechen ich kann
michael wir geben uns okay michael baar
nein eben nicht das ist ja eher ein
micky maus gibt es schon den sprecher
und das ist durch das was gesucht wird
und muss auch keine super tolle stimme
haben wenn du mich fragst ich finde
meine stimme gar nicht schön aber jeder
hat einen charakter hin und zu jeder
stimme wobei handwerk ganz kurz ich habe
früher kluge mädchen gesprochen richtig
ihn zum beispiel ja mittlerweile spreche
ich gebrochen irgendwelche alten ich bin
schon längst mutter ich bin kurz war oma
das ist sehr traurig also ist und du
siehst okay
okay also
wann bist du dir so diese jungen klugen
mädchen oder ist es jetzt so naja es ist
was auch interessant ist ich habe bei
gretchen mir vielleicht nicht bei
gretchen bei vielen rollen keine ahnung
ich hab im kindergarten das deutsch
gelernt und dann kanns noch nicht mal
alle deutschen wörter und dann kommen so
plötzlich fremdwörtern diese sprechen
muss weil die rolle so klug ist und
irgendwas
von physik und chemie und du verstehst
ich habe ganz oft sachen gesagt ich
nicht verstanden das ist ganz witzig
mittlerweile käme ich wahrscheinlich
klar wobei ich manchmal so internet und
computer nerds habe mädels spreche ich
auch noch manchmal da weiß ich auch
nicht was sie sagt und dann musst du
ganz oft wahrscheinlich wiederholen weil
die aussprache muss ja auch passen jan
bei gretchen auf einer story auf deine
frage um auf deine frage zurückzukommen
also ja schauspieltalent ist das auto
meiner meinung nach also wenn du ein
schauspieler kannst und nicht willst
dann bist du bei der synchro nicht
richtig ein okay und ich würde jedem
empfehlen schauspiel zu machen ich bin
da reingewachsen und klar aber so
sprecher für perfekte aussprache ist
wichtig meiner meinung nach und lust am
schauspielen und und würdest du auch mal
vor die kamera würdest du auch mal in so
einem film mitspielen oder wisse daher
schüchtern was mir nicht vorstellen kann
übrigens gerade ja also ich lange zeit
habe ich mich dagegen gestreut aber wenn
was interessant ist und cooles kämen
dann ungarns wären okay vielleicht sieht
man sich ja also im nächsten blockbuster
ja genau irgendeine bank ausrauben
severin oder so
als irgendwelche sie könnte ich richtig
gut und dann so ein ding raus richtig
ich merke das vorstellen der tu berlin
um wege stand wir tranken jetzt israel
in dem wie sie nach einer sprecherrolle
fragen die sie nie hatte also esther
deine liste an sprecherrollen ist ja
sehr lange sie hat mir die mayo guckt
und da gibt es einige filme die sich so
bekannte hast auch cougar ja kashi in
kabul
und wie war das für dich weil es ist ja
auch von ganz anderer film eine
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
[Applaus]
hat dieses war das abgesprochen die ich
gemeinsam geht es nochmal bremer firma
versionen du wirst heute blockierten
zu sagen du musst eigentlich da
rausgehen oder raus von 100 wieder
schaffen machen
jetzt komme ich erschlagen wollte ich
kenne ja auch
wenn sein kommt so hinter den kulissen
wiesheu die zicke eigens dafür sind was
sehen wo es wirklich andere liga wie sie
wirklich
recht da ist ja das reicht so kann es
gerne jetzt schon mal darauf geben und
ich verstreicht das dann unterstreicht
sich überhaupt noch auf machen ja ich
werde auch die kochsendung übernehmen ja
super gerne ohne geld ist ja hallo meine
lieben dass rami m
und ich muss sagen ist randvoll den halb
gerade jetzt auch auf social media na ja
und in nieste besserer wie findest du
das ich ist aus versehen passiert
ehrlich gesagt war so nicht geplant aber
es ist schon schön wenn leute das feiern
was du machst ja du hast ja mega also
was hast du auf victor coste 150 tausend
follower oder so glaub nicht ganz so
viel aber ja das mit tik tok war
wirklich nur spontan
und ich habe niemals mit so einem hype
gerechnet und starte ich versuche das
einfach mal das ist so durch die decke
gegangen ja und dann dachte ich bleibe
ich dran und jetzt muss ich noch mal
wieder ein bisschen aktiver werden also
wird auch auf der straße schon erkannt
ja selten aber schon und wir sagen wie
danach das ist okay oder astra wie mio
also ich habe mit meinem besten freund
mit macho man erlebt dass wir zusammen
in düsseldorf waren unabhängig davon
dass er mich gerne verarscht damit dass
er zu den leuten oft heute zum beispiel
er geht auf jemanden zu und sagt ja
übrigens haben wir sie haben sie die
stimme erkannt und er sein sollte und er
soja sie ganz bekannte
synchronsprecherin
ein tv so okay und ich dankbar und macht
sich zu befreien muss sich der reale
morgen sehen sehr gewünschte
unangenehmer moment und in düsseldorf
kam mal die situation auch da war es
relativ neu da war auch mein tik tok
relativ neu und dann standen wir da
unterhalten mal so und ich uns und
plötzlich wie höheren sonnig und die
ganze zeit im hintergrund und irgendwann
habe ich so ganz bewusst so während des
gesprächs war du hast du aus dem
hintergrund
aber das durchgängig
erschreckt habe umgedreht habe
tatsächlich werde ich mit jockey
angesprochen jetzt aber ist wenn jemand
gesagt dass du mich und mein bergen okay
das ist aber auch die die natürlich die
bekannteste rolle aber so ganz aktuell
ja im moment der aktuell wo man ganz
schnell die palette dann kannst du
einmal sagt verstreichen ja und
ich kümmern so warst ganz ehrlich aber
hast für alles irgend etwas im leben
kommen ganz ehrlich da ich dir mal was
sagen wo ist dieses teil kommt mit dem
dings da hätte ich es nicht richten dass
er wieso
guck mal ich zeig dir das geht absolut
bitte leute geht
gibt kein geld aus
das muss raus
eigentlich hat das volk gegen das bo ja
ich versuche ja und das geht wirklich
nicht ganz gut ist
also guck mal pipi ich bring dir das
jetzt mal bei so machst das damit ja
es ist nicht so schön klar du musst du
ja und ich verstehe jetzt den sehnerv
intakt
[Musik]
doch jetzt
der bank von spanien
hahahahaha spricht doch alle hier ich
bin gekommen verarscht zu werden macht
das richtig erwarten ja das machst du
schon sagst du ja ich würde ja also
braucht man doch die hereingabe 2.0 aus
was wie heißt das ding 2.0 ist die
provinz
wir hatten keine andere und dann habe
ich noch mal verbessert weiß was das
ding ist ich lerne so ich habe ja
natürlich viel zu aber auch so ich hab
mal beim synchron bei einem auf einer
rolle die übrigens auch sehr mochte habe
ich muss dich gipfel sagen büffel dafür
recht so was ein gipfel ist ne so jetzt
kommt das ist das ist ein löffel gabel
löffel kreuzungen ich glaube mit der
macht uns zum servieren ein ja gut so
ich glaube dass daraus oder so was hab
ich weiß nicht mehr was aber tatsächlich
kann ich den begriff nicht und ich habe
den gelesen also im
buch sozusagen als mit exakt ich dachte
ich werde schon wieder verarscht ein
roter faden meines lebens und damit die
leute wollen mich verarschen nur weiß
migrationshintergrund haben und jetzt
nicht mit migrationshintergrund spielen
dessen das gehört ja das ist ein gipfel
tatsächlich existiert so was und dann
wusste man schon dass das existiert ich
wollte alles was das heißt also ich
lerne auch hier dazu duncan russell will
kann sich auch noch nicht immer und ich
hab sie ihr wissen das ist den kreislauf
des lebens
geht einmaligen
bei casey ist doch vorne heute so gesagt
ist so
ok kannte tierköpfen genau jetzt in die
kommentare was du dich trennen
interessieren ok also dass jetzt auch
schon mal super aus stehen wir können
jetzt diese abschließende geschichte
machen und dafür gefallen zu tun
[Musik]
also für den guss haben wir jetzt sagt
und erdbeeren einmal püriert jetzt gebe
ich noch speisestärke dazu und dann
kannst du einfach hin und dann kochen
wir das einmal auf ok und wie ist es so
wenn du unterwegs bist sagen dann alle
so ey manchmal tokio oder so merkte ich
das auch mal also nerven nicht aber es
ist schon sehr unangenehm ehrlich gesagt
am kleber es willst du nicht so in der
öffentlichkeit oder wie ist das nie also
na ich freue mich schon so im nachhinein
dinge kohl die finden das toll was ich
mache aber ich habe auch so situationen
dass man dann sagt so ganz laut und dann
sitzt man in einer location dann kommt
einer und sagt ey kannst du mal bitte
kurz tokio machen und dann sagst aber
verlor vor ich würde ich kann nicht und
dann hast du da macht man musik aus seit
mir alle rutschen dann personals und die
stühle
in deine richtung drehen und in ruhe so
wenn du eine stecknadel fallen lassen
würde ist man würde gehirn ihr
ja klar
da kann ich nicht aber das ist ja es
tatsächlich manchmal nicht unangenehm
okay was immer gar nicht was ich sagen
wollte wie beschreibt die situation bist
richtig in diesem du bist in diesem raum
und siehst du leute will sie lang aber
er sei charmant geantwortet wenn jetzt
das jahr oder so naja ich bin ja auch
mal ich verstehe das ja auch das ist das
schlimmer so also mich nervt wirklich
aber weil du das hat immer wieder machen
muss und weil wirklich unangenehm aber
ich verstehe auch die andere seite wenn
du dich damals vielleicht auch bei dir
so dass die leute die halten dich und
die finden das toll gemacht so ja aber
hast du auch schon diesen diesen drang
bist du immer so wenn in der stadt ist
es doch mal wie schlecht gelaunt durch
die stadt lockt jaja erlösen das kannst
du nicht da fühlst du dich schon
beobachter ja dabei da ja und vorher
fertig und so war das gar nicht so ne
überhaupt nicht also ist ziert sich so
dass ich auf der kampf werde aber das
risiko ist natürlich ein ja dass sie
jederzeit mal jemanden er heute gern
rauchen oder war ich voll krank und so
also wäre ich auch richtig schlimm auch
besser hoffentlich was mich jetzt kann
er erkennen und dann war da tatsächlich
eine stadt die hat gar nicht
interessiert wie es aussehen das ist
wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht schlecht
aus
liste.de gespräch der rennen
apropos krank werden wie es manche noch
mal heisser bist und vor allem wie so
oft eine längere über 5 kennt
durchschnitt also für einen längeren
zeitraum
wie ist das dann so also ganz normalen
job verlieren wenn es so ist er also
tatsächlich wenn du mal ganz ganz lange
krank bist besteht das risiko aber
mir zum glück noch nie passiert was mir
passiert ist natürlich dass ich mal
heiser war die produktion konnte zum
glück dann immer warten oder was auch
passiert ist im fall von es ist ja das
interessante daran war ich heiser und
ihr hatte ich doch nichts ist so oder so
eine nebenrolle und ich würde es
natürlich auch sehen besetzt und ich war
mega mega heiß und dann mag ich meine
stimme wenn ich heiser bin ich ja etwas
merkt es mag das und dann tut man sich
ja ja ja das mag das und ich habe vorher
angriff nicht mehr also ich bin ein
bisschen heiser ich glaube ich kann
heute nicht immer hinter mir ist egal
wir drehen hier heute ab also die stimme
bleibt so kommt statt wenn es eine serie
serie wäre wäre es komisch denn die
rolle anfängt irgendwie heißer zu
sprechen und dann hört sich normal wird
für eine folge geht es genau das gegen
absolute und er meint es passt der rolle
also können wir also und deshalb
wirklich wie die faust aufs auge passt
alles besser als wenn ich gesund
gesprochen hat und wenn du eine folge
dreht ich weiß wie dann geht die so eine
halbe stunde im schnitt in mega
unterschiedlich aber ja vielleicht halbe
stunde zwischen also dann machst du am
tag auch mehrere folgen mal so ganz
acht-stunden-tag oder eher
wahrscheinlich mal drauf an wer kommt
mega darauf an vor allem wenn du in
einer anderen stadt sprichst dann
versucht man das auf so wenige tage wie
möglich so aufzuteilen ja okay und was
seine stimme jetzt angeht gibt es da
irgendwelche tricks wie du die chance
oder was ist ja nun mal irgendwie
richtig reis oder sogar sowie wie machst
du das mit einer stimme also tatsächlich
wenn ich ganz ganz viel spreche besteht
das risiko dass sich heiser wer da merke
ich meine stimmbänder so ein bisschen
überfordert und dann versuche ich halt
so in der freizeit nicht allzuviel laut
zu sein ich nicht zu singen das empfehle
ich sowieso nicht mich beim singen
hierzu zugenommen ich kann gar nicht
kennst du singen ich nun wirklich nicht
wirklich mal sowas ist so gern singen
ich hab doch echt nicht aber ich würde
es gern könnte weist auch schon gern
hören ich würde alles meist nicht und
ahs ist nicht die piraten es war außer
ich habe es auch gehört es war aus
versehen okay
ich kann eigentlich gar nicht wegen aber
ohne singen rolle also gibt's die gibt's
nirgendwo
ja wir hören das stück ist und was
machst du so während wir hier die
aufsicht sei es geht hier nur um uns
okay
je nachdem ob ein bisschen zucker noch
mit 312 ist echt jahr gar nicht also ist
süß genug gemacht denn ich muss nochmal
probieren ob alles ok also ja
und so nicht mehr ich bin nicht ganz auf
den geschmack gekommen
ich schwöre voll lecker
ich denke immer noch mal
ja weiß okay das ist ganz wichtig wir
müssen gucken die das ja klar also so
lange genug genug übrigens
wenn du schaltest
die j hier gearbeitet
ok also ihr merkt schon dass irgendein
bisher ein bisschen schauspielerei habe
die beide im blut das bringt es glaube
ich so richtig witzig genau erzähl mir
von meinen tipps wie du deine stimme so
bei laune ja also wie ich die pflege
werde ich auch ganz oft gefragt aber
tatsächlich mache ich nicht
aber ich was ich gerne kommen wenn du
sprichst ja auch viel vor der kamera zum
beispiel
den trick hab ich schon öfter mal
geteilt den hab ich selbst empfohlen
bekommt und zwar dann passiert das wenn
du vom mikro stehst hast du dich
manchmal verhasst ist aber völlig
grundlos ist das richtig was ich mache
perfekt ja okay ich kanns ja das ist
voll drauf
die nächsten sendungen wertigkeit für
dann die leute ein sozusagen du
interviews und ich für die leute ein
also ich finde auch so als team und so
das ist richtig cool zu resignieren was
mein handy noch ein paar mal einladen
darf man jetzt in die kommentare ja es
könnt ihr euch selbst überlegen aber
so jetzt mit dem teilnehmer ich würde
sagen komm mach du denn so toll ich bin
so ein piano mafia hat alles per stift
aus der hand gerissen kann ich weiß ich
habe mir dann so richtig durchdrehe das
jetzt macht der flick der den trick und
zwar verhaspelt man sich aber völlig
grundlos längst es erst gar keine warum
kann ich jetzt am passt da nicht
aussprechen
und dann
nimmst du so ein das ist der korken test
oder der korken versuch keine ahnung wie
man das nicht aber auf jeden fall mit
dem korken normalerweise nimmt den
korken im mund spricht den satz nach
meinen mit korken im mund und dann
nämlich den korken raus und ich schwöre
dir du kannst diesen satz aussprechen
als ob du nichts anderes in der mensa
kann man das was das problem war doch
robinho ist aber das ist so ein riesen
lesen konnten ja überhaupt kein problem
vielleicht sogar besser
ja ich mache was ich machen ich habe ja
nicht ein korken dabei auf arbeit fragt
doch mal wie ich das mache kicker wie
machst du das nenne ich mache den
flugstrecken
aber stimmt tatsächlich ich nehme den
finger schon zum beispiel ich konnte
nicht sagen ich weiß doch wie zitronen
wollen und ich sage ich möchte heute bin
ich wollte mich ich wollte heute und
dann kriegt mich hinter meister ich
wollte heute rio krone holen so und dann
kommt startband engine 123 die aufnahmen
ich wollte heute bio zitronen holen und
dann gehen und dann hast du ja irgendwie
funktioniert das im marke ich möchte
immer ausprobieren
komplizierten wachs für mich in meiner
psychisch soziologischen konstellation
manifestiert sich die absolute dominanz
positiver impressionen eines individuums
ok ich sag einfach in meiner psychisch
dustmann soziologischen konstellation
christoph reichenau
in meiner psychische theologischen
konstellation
oder ja vielleicht ja doch zu dessen job
es funktioniert leute und diesen korken
gibt auch zu ende
aber das ist also ein bäcker aus china
als ich glaube es wenn man so ein klein
korken hat dann leicht dass auch jahre
kommen ok
vor interessant ja also das mit dem
korken kriegst du mal gebracht bregenz
habe ich mit dem korken trick mein ich
misch dich fehler weg bekomme ich kann
jetzt ich sagen oder dich
hefte wie lange hast du da wir dann habe
ich dafür gebraucht hätte ich hätte
bürger ich weiß gar nicht
konzentriert
ich bin der es kann sehr dankbar dafür
weil ich gerade von wem hast du diesen
text
sieht es also so wie jetzt auch noch als
eine ein problem hat dann einfach den
korken trick versuchen was aber ich
würde ich werde voll di bacco ihnen
vor allem zu essen so jetzt sich einmal
durch das heißt nichts lösen ja
hallo gut auf was haben wir denn neben
bekommen über vier können
zu hause haben schon
jetzt probieren wir nicht richtig
gespannt wie das schmeckt eigentlich
müssten ja haben sah und master den
preis oder auge haben ja eigentlich ist
mir auch probleme aber ich musste es
probieren er finde ich auch
mit
neutral denn tmn
zwar noch nicht so viele tv kamera aber
wir sind ehrlich das heißt den klaren
erfolg uhr somit rio zu essen ist so rio
so konsistent ist schon mal super
der geruch 1
dann war man testen oder so ist das noch
bist du das nie gehabt noch der sieg war
man atmet das einfach so weg hier habe
ich das gelernt
das ist kiki hast du echt zum 50
also ich weiß dass es richtig packen
kann aber jetzt sagen danke also ich
finde es als ob mir gemacht
wird dass du deine hilfe ich habe
wirklich was dazugelernt unabhängig von
dem kuchen auch was ist für
berggipfel und so
[Gelächter]
18 absolut und desto leichter macht
diesen weg
sollte man einfach einen sturm schalten
und einfach nur beim essen zu ja genau
wir waren schlecht weil zu viel wasser
am ende soll dann muss abspann von wo
die ganzen namen
dann muss man so tun müssen wir nochmals
spannend
also jetzt mal spaß beiseite ich mit den
echten mega auch voll die sommer torten
leute dort sagen für den sommer perfekt
jetzt nicht dieses interview denn ich
glaube ja so ein zehn minuten real und
wackers wieder an haben wir das in die
länge gestreckt vier stunden oder so
aber am ende schneiden wir 30 50 minuten
zusammen fast aber dass auch spannendes
zu erzählen gehabt muss ich sagen also
eigentlich bin ich ja dafür dass das
regelmäßig kommst und weitere fragen
habt oder so schreibt sie doch einfach
in die kommentare vielleicht kommt der
zweite teil zustande ich werde ein
gesuch fragen wieso nicht wirklich mega
fraglich da müssen wir was machen muss
tokio tokio ich bin neben den test ist
ja tatsächlich weil ich so christa tokio
mit ich bin raus das ist auf jeden fall
später einen kuchen mit
[Gelächter]
es kommt der traurige teil ich
verabschiede mich von dir und nicht fand
mega cool dass sie hier was ist auch
offen als beantwortet hat hier hilft
auch gern mal ihre seite abchecken ich
werde sie als ersten link in der infobox
parken schaut auf jeden fall mal vorbei
und ansonsten man hört sich mit
es war schön dass sich hier was und wenn
ihr mehr über es erfahren möchte schaut
unten in die beschreibung da habe ich
deine social media account verlinkt und
ansonsten würde ich mich freuen wenn du
in einer synchro stimme vielleicht noch
mal so ein klein abschied an die kita
mühlberg
elbe community es hat mir riesenspaß
gemacht in eurer community dabei sein zu
dürfen hoffentlich bis zum nächsten mal
mega
mega mega